the time of transition from Steve Jobs
as leader of Apple to Tim Cook was an
incredibly charged moment very close to
his own death he said to Tim Cook I
don't ever want you to ask what would
Steve Jobs do I want you to do what is
right
none of the genius that is attributed to
Steve Jobs would ever been able to
happen had it not been for the supply
chain that Tim Cook built and when he
started there wasn't much of a supply
chain Apple actually made a lot of its
own products then Tim Cook dismantled
that he began to assemble an amazing
sort of chain of suppliers Apple would
deeply deeply integrate with these
suppliers going way up River to
fundamental technologies so that they
would be the first in line to get them
and they would be made to the standards
that Apple wanted the combination of all
those things gave Apple and advantage
that to this day no other electronics
company has and it's very hard to
imagine that anyone ever would the Apple
watch is the most advanced timepiece
ever created to say Oh cook hasn't come
out with an amazing groundbreaking
product like Steve Jobs as well the
climate isn't quite ready for that to
happen things like the iPhone the iPad
the iPod were the product of the right
moment when memory became affordable and
processors became more energy-efficient
and display technology reached a certain
point that you could start to actually
make those products I would argue that
right now we're a little bit in-between
the next big moment
he remains the only openly homosexual
CEO of a fortune 500 company which seems
shocking but it's true his own privacy
was becoming outweighed by the need to
contribute to a raising of tolerance he
seems to now have moved into other areas
as well he has been very vocal on the
aspects of privacy he has made the
company very environmentally responsible
and he famously said something along the
lines of we are trying to leave the
world better for our children than it
was for us and if you're not interested
in us doing that you should get out of
our stuff when you're out in the wild
you will see max everywhere now they're
in businesses they're in coffee shops in
airports and hopefully they're in your
living room kook occupies a position in
business that arguably no other person
does Apple has actually performed better
financially under Tim Cook than it had
under Steve Jobs so he has a lot of wind
behind his sails if you will to be able
to be in the vanguard and he wants to
use it so that his legacy isn't just
supply chains and product development
but also potentially a different way
that companies can behave in the world
and affect real change